foreign
members officers members of the public
welcome to this extraordinary cabinet
meeting
at firearm procedures if the fire alarm
is activated vacate the officers by the
stairs please do not use the lifts
assembling holy Square on the green
officers will assist you in advise when
it seems safe to return to the chamber
please switch off or turn to silent your
mobile phones and do not make or receive
calls while the meeting's in progress
please note this meeting has been live
streamed for members of the public the
meeting will also be recorded and
something made available on the internet
does anyone intend to film the meeting
like the fellow members have asked to
speak under Council procedure rule 20.1
item 4 Council of bayford are there any
other members requested to speak
councilor cup I suspect you want to
speak on item three don't you it's not
leader you're absolutely right could I
speak under gender item three please
thank you I'm sure we can accommodate
you
I apologies I have apologies from
councilor Whitehead and councilor Yates
you can't get any more apologies because
that's the rest of the cabinet
item two uh does anyone have any
interest to declaring the items of
business on the agenda this evening
no thank you item three is the
birchington drive neighborhood plan
which is for me to introduce
under the localism ACT 2011 neighborhood
plans could be prepared by local
communities and are led by town or
Parish councils or a neighborhood Forum
in areas which do not have a town or
Parish Council your FANUC Council adopts
a neighborhood plan it will have the
same significance as other development
plan documents for example the local
plan for the district birchington Parish
Council has prepared a draft
neighborhood plan it was published and
formally submitted to the council and
has subsequently been assessed by an
independent Examiner the examiner's
report has also been published it
supports the proposed neighborhood plan
with some minor modifications and
recommends that it be subject to a
referendum the council now has to issue
a decision statement as to whether or
not he accepts the recommendations in
the examiner's report and if not why
actions will be necessary Council also
has to consider whether the draft plan
meets the basic conditions for a
neighborhood plan
report before cabinet sets out relevant
issues in the examiner's report for
cabinet's decision which will also form
the basis of the decision statement the
draft neighborhood plan is generally
supported it has been positively
prepared and includes policies that
generally conform with the adopted local
plan
it's encouraging to say that the parish
council has included policies which are
though too detailed or too specific for
the local plan do generally support the
delivery of the local plan and have a
good evidence base I therefore propose
the recommendations are set out in the
report that is that the birchington
neighborhood plan be modified with the
modifications set out in the examiner's
report and X1 and that the council
issues a decision statement that the
plan should proceed to referendum to
have a second please
councilor I'm going to give back to
councilor Keane on the basis that's uh
yeah previous previous meetings yeah
thank you councilor cup
thank you leader um and I know I speak
on behalf of all of my fellow birchton
District councilors when I say it is
very encouraging that we are seeing this
come to Cabinet I know how frustrating
it's been
um for the parish to uh have such delays
but it is incredibly positive that we're
here this evening I think it's very
important that we are doing everything
we can to encourage our towns and
villages to have such policies in place
to ensure that we don't lose our
identities of those towns and Villages
and these neighborhood plans are vital
to ensure that when developments go
ahead that they are in line with what
the village or town want and I would
just like to also say thank you to the
team at the parish council for their
hard work and getting this all together
um I know how much time and effort has
been put into getting everything
together and how patient they've had to
be as well so I hope this evening the
cabinets support the recommendation for
the good birchington thank you chair
I don't think there was a question in
there but thank you for your comments
members any discussion councilor album
yeah it's just a question uh please data
for um Mr Mr Vero if he would be so kind
I think sometimes uh our residents get
get confused in relation to a
neighborhood plan when it's in re when
it's concerning dealing with the
planning application and
um and I know that the the neighborhood
plans are weighted and I'd just like to
know
how high they are weighted
um so is it low medium the higher or
somewhere in between any any of those
um and and how that affects a planning
application in conjunction with the
local plan thank you
Mr well
yes thank you uh neighborhood plans are
given the same weight as the local plan
so when case officers are looking at
policies that affect a particular
development they will look at both local
pound policies
and neighborhood plan policies at the
same time
thank you
so members cabinet's been asked to agree
that the draft label plan be modified to
sit out in the report but the council
issues a decision statement that it
accepts a recommendation in the
examiner's report and the draft
neighborhood plan can proceed to
referendum the members agree
thank you
item four which is the broadstairs and
St Peter's neighborhood plan
this was made in May 2021 since then
Brill stairs and Saint Peters Town
Council have been reviewing the plan
the process for a neighborhood plan
review depends on the significance of
the changes being made as set out in the
National planning policy guidance in
this case the changes were considered to
be significant enough to change the
nature of the plan and therefore require
an examination and referendum the
changes include updated objectives three
new policies and the introduction of a
design code
the plan review was published and
formally submitted to the council and
has subsequently been accessed by an
independent examiner the examiner's
report has also been published it
supports the proposed neighborhood plan
with some minor modifications and
recommends that it be subject to a
referendum Council now is to issue a
decision statement as to whether or not
he accepts the recommendation in the
examiner's report and if not why actions
will be necessary the council also has
to consider whether the draft plan
review meets the basic conditions for a
neighborhood plan
report before cabinet sets out relevant
issues in the examiner's report for
cabinet's decision which will also form
the basis of the decision statement
a draft neighborhood plan is generally
supported
if I didn't scroll the wrong way
draft neighbor plan is generally
supported it's been positively prepared
and has been brought up to date on a
number of issues including climate
change and social changes as a result of
the pandemic I therefore propose the
recommendations as set out in the report
that is the broadstairs and St Peters
neighborhood plan review be modified
with the modifications and the
examiner's report Annex one and that the
council issues a decision statement that
the plan should proceed to referendum is
there a second to please
I'll give that one to councilor
Duckworth thank you councilor Byford you
want to speak thank you leader again not
a question but having served on the
broad citizens of Peter's neighborhood
plan subcommittee I'm aware of the huge
amount of targeted work that's been
undertaking in order to produce the
second edition neighborhood plan I thank
all those concerned for this the plan
takes account of Major World changes
relating to slowing climate change
reducing carbon emissions and the rapid
social changes result of the kovi 19
pandemic it has also been amended to
address issues raised through
consultation and the proposed
modifications recommended by The
Examiner I hope that tonight he
disagreed for the plan to proceed from
to referendum thank you
thank you councilor Beaufort members any
comments
okay so members are asked to agree that
the draft neighbor plan review will be
modified as set out in the report and
that the council issues a decision
statement that it accepts
recommendations of the examiners report
and the draft Naval plan can proceed to
referendum to members agree thank you
that concludes the business for
tonight's meeting and I declare the
meeting closed at 7 10.
live stream of the meeting will now end
thank you for your attendance